there have been pretty serious questions
for a long time about First Lady Melania
Trump's legal and immigration status
when she came to the United States and
we have every reason to believe that she
was working illegally here modeling on a
visa that doesn't allow her to actually
be doing any work and we were told way
back when I don't even remember when at
this point couple years ago maybe that
there would be a press conference to
clear all of that up it was scheduled to
be I guess at some point and it's never
happened and it's clearly not going to
happen but now there's a whole new set
of questions about this and this matters
not only because the first lady of the
United States shouldn't have
questionable immigration circumstances
in her past but also and most
importantly because so much of Donald
Trump's focus during his campaign has
been on illegal immigration and visas
and the wall and deportations and
so-called extreme vetting and what we've
now learned from a new Washington Post
article is that back in the year 2000
Melania was dating Donald Trump at the
time imagine that imagine dating Donald
Trump it's already horrible and she
started asking for a permanent residency
in the United States on the basis of
extraordinary ability this is the e b1
visa it's sometimes known as an Einstein
visa and it's for people who have as the
name suggests very crazy hair no an
extraordinary ability or skills or a job
where you simply can't find an American
to do it as well or something very very
unique right and that immediately gets
me wondering what exactly we're Melania
Trump's arm at the time Melania mouses
credentials that would justify giving
her an e b1 visa right she had been in
the swimsuit edition of Sports
Illustrated wearing a string bikini and
although there might have been some
interesting elements of physics
portrayed in that picture I don't think
she's exactly a physicist that warrants
an eb1 visa and in the following year
she got that eb1
visa most people who get that visa are
academic researchers or business
executives from really big multinational
firms Olympic athlete
oscar-winning actors who have quote
sustained national and international
acclaim not random relatively obscure
models and in general only a fraction of
1% of the million green cards issued
that year went to people with
extraordinary abilities and we're
supposed to believe that Melania
deserved to be one of those people so
first and foremost was there cronyism
was there potentially even more than
that at play bribery who knows but it
all stinks that's number one number two
this is yet another instance of Trump
pushing policy to appease his base
that's totally disconnected from how he
lives his life because if we are to
presume or suspect that there was some
special treatment for Melania on the
basis of being Donald Trump's girlfriend
at the time then it stands to reason
that Donald Trump lived his life in a
very different way than what he's
advocating in terms of policy and a
couple of weeks ago I raised the
question of how Melania Trump parents
are here because it seems more and more
clear that Melania Trump parents are
here because they were sponsored for
so-called chained migration by Melania
Trump which is a policy that Donald
Trump wants to end but for today the
major new question is how and which
immigration authorities thought that
Melania Trump warranted an e b1 visa I
don't know the answer but I can't think
of how we would say let's give her the
Einstein right and normally I wouldn't
really care that much about the
immigration status of any one particular
person absolutely the hypocrisy that
really gets to me here that's right it's
the same thing about how Melania Trump
is going to champion the effort against
cyberbullying oh right yeah and yet her
husband is the chief cyber bully err I
mean there's a clear connection here no
question about it it is mostly the
hypocrisy I don't as I said before I
don't want Melania Trump deported I
don't want Melania Trump sperits
deported I want the hypocrisy to stop
and I want the cronyism to stop and I
want the nepotism to stop and the
criteria for the eb1 visa the criteria
are subjective to a degree right but
there is the
rule of thumb which is only the top two
percent of people in their field qualify
Melania wasn't even in the top two
percent of European models she really
wasn't even in the top two percent of
foreign girlfriends of American rich
dudes I don't even know what that means
I'm kind of kidding but she was not in
the bigger scheme of things a notable
person and the only extraordinary thing
I've seen her do is tolerate being
married to Trump to be perfectly honest
so if it was some world renowned
supermodel like Gisele Bundchen I think
this would make sense but given the fact
that she was obscure and not too
well-known yeah in Europe listen it
doesn't make sense you can make the case
that it would make more sense to give
Giselle the eb1 visa
of course I think ultimately she became
an American citizen because she married
an American lady I don't even know I
mean I don't know just cells background
but right you can make a stronger case
for Giselle but you can also make a case
against Giselle and if you can make the
case against Giselle getting an ev1 visa
then the case against Melania getting it
is completely obvious
so the hypocrisy knows no bounds the
questions are not being answered
milania's spokespeople and White House
staff were asked Melania are milania's
parents here because of the same chain
migration that trump wants to eliminate
we didn't get an answer to that
questions have started what is the
explanation for Melania Trump having
received an Einstein visa an e b1 visa
back in 2001 and we've gotten super
general and broad statements like she
was more than qualified for the visa as
I don't know if they called her an
internationally renowned model and sort
of like a humanitarian or what exactly
the framing was we're just not getting
answers and you know what maybe we just
have to accept that we're not going to
get the answers ever yeah if only
Michelle Obama was an immigrant herself
right then Melania Trump would have a
speech to copy that exam hey and you
know what if Michelle Obama had been
born in another country she actually
would have maybe merited an e b1 visa
didn't she go to Harvard and a very
well-respected and brilliant a lot law
lawyer
she actually might have qualified for an
ev1 visa by any sort of reasonable
standards send me your thoughts what the
hell is going on here with Melania Trump
and immigration and eb1 visas and the
hypocrisy of the possible chain
migration I'm on Twitter at D Pakman
follow me there the show is on Twitter
at David Pakman show today's program is
sponsored in part by fruit or the tour
is a social forecasting game where
players come together and compete with
each other to predict future events you
open up the game on your phone or web
browser you'll see a whole range of
forecasts covering topics across the
board politics sports so much more you
wager on predictions about real world
events using food tours in game fake
currency and you earn more of this
currency every time you make a
prediction that comes true you can show
off your prediction skills to friends
improve your forecasting ability I'm
even on futur you can find my account by
clicking the link in the description if
you're watching this on YouTube and this
week on futur I posed the question will
robert molars trump russia investigation
end during this year during 2018 what do
you think place your bets and you can
sign up now at fruit or calm and start
making your forecasts on political
topics and so many other topics it's
free and it's available on both Android
and iOS as well as on web browsers
that's fut you you are calm